[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد في برنامجكم
الندوه وصالونها اليوم ايضا سيكون عن يوم
التاسيس كما كان في الحلقه الماضيه ونحن
نشهد الاستعدادات والاحتفالات والاحتفاءات
بهذا اليوم وهو جدير بذلك وحقيق بذلك لانه
يوم يعيد لنا وعينا التاريخي بشكل اكثر
صحه واكثر سلامه اذ انه يؤسس لبدايه
الدوله منذ تولى مؤسسها الامير محمد بن
سعود ثم الامام اصبح لقب محمد بن سعود
الاماره في الدرعيه وما حواليها قبل
التاريخ الذي تعودنا عليه او 1744 لا قبل
ذلك بكثير
1727 يعني فتره ليست بالسهله ضيفنا اليوم
وشريكنا كما كان في الحلقه الماضيه
الدكتور راشد العساكر وهو باحث سعودي
ومؤرق سعودي
له عنايه خاصه بتاريخ الدوله السعوديه
الاولى والثانيه والثالثه كذلك كما يملك
شغفا خاص بهذا الامر وانا بالنسبه لي اي
انسان يملك شغف في اي موضوع اعتقد هو
الاجدر بالحديث من غيره ما بالك اذا اضاف
اليه علما واطلاعا واتقانا فمرحبا بك
دكتور راشد في هذه الحلقه توقفنا في
الحلقه الماضيه كان عند مظاهر
الفقدان الامن في هذا الاقليم اقليم
العارض وما حواليه وكيف ان هذا الفقدان
معبر عنه في الشعر الشعبي الذي اشرنا الى
نماذج منه ذكرها الدكتور سعد الصويان مثلا
رميزان ابن غشام جابر بن سيار حميدان
الشويعر حينما تحلل شعرهم تجد هذا الطلب
الشديد على وجود سلطه مركزيه وقضاء عادل
يلم هذا الشتات حسب قراءه سعد الصبيان
وحسبك وحسبك بها من قراءه ثم تعرضت الى
الى بعض مواقف العلماء
وايضا غيرهم حياله فقدان الامن في البلاد
النجديه والبلاد العارض منها بشكل ادق
اليوم نريد بعد ان قامت هذه الدوله
استعرضت محمد بن سعود قبل من لحظه توليه
لاماره الدرعيه وطموحه الى توسيع هذه
الاماره
نشات الدوله السعوديه الاولى ثم بلغت اوجه
كما يقال في عهد الامام سعود حدثنا عن
مظاهر هذه الدوله ولنبدا بالمظاهر
العمرانيه اليوم الناس يتحدثون عن الطريف
والجيري
اولا طبعا
هناك مراحل ايضا سابقه قبل الامام سعود بن
عبد العزيز بن سعود بن عبد العزيز بن محمد
بن سعود وكان والده الامام ايضا عبد
العزيز محمد بن مسعود وكان ايضا الايمان
محمد بن سعود عندما شرع ايضا محمد بن سعود
في هذه الانطلاق الكبرى وايضا محاوله
لملمه هذه البلاد المتراميه الاطراف
وخصوصا في منطقه العارض استطاع ايضا هناك
يقوم بحملات عسكريه ايضا ضد مدينه الرياض
استمرت 28 سنه 28 سنه الحقيقه التاريخ ليس
سهلا وايضا هناك حوادث تاريخيه بينه ايضا
بين الرياض ربما بلغت اكثر من 34 موقع
تاريخيه قتل فيها الحقيقه عدد يعني من اهل
الدرعيه وايضا في الرياض كان محمد بن سعود
ايضا يسعى لهذه السيطره وايضا لملمه هذه
الاطراف المتناحره في هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي استطاع وتمكن ايضا من دخول
الرياض في 19 ربيع الاول تقريبا في عام
1127 في يوم العصر فاستطاع الامام بعد
وفاته طبعا الامام محمد بن سعود تولى
الامام عبد العزيز واستطاع ايضا اكمال
المسيره وايضا دخول الرياض فتوسعت بالتالي
هذه الدوله فاستطاعت ايضا هذا التوسع الذي
ادى الى دخول الرياض كان في الدوله
السعوديه ان تتوسع ايضا وتتمدد من ناحيه
الجنوبيه وغيرها ثم انتشر ايضا هذا التوسع
الكبير وبلغ اثره في عهد الامام سعود بن
عبد العزيز بن محمد بن سعود سعود بن عبد
العزيز يسمى سعود الكبير وهو اقصى فتره
الحقيقه بلغت اوجه الدوله السعوديه العهد
الذهبي اهم من شمال الجزيره العربيه من
جنوب حوران الى ايضا الحديده من جنوب
حوران الى شمال حديده وايضا من البحر الى
البحر فاستقر الحقيقه الدوله السعوديه
ومناسبه
في احدى روائعه لا تشتبه بالخوارط والحدود
الحدود من الحديده بس على ذكر حينما ذكر
برزت ايضا في هذه الدوله وايضا دخول موارد
جديده وايضا التوسع العسكري والتوسع
الثقافي وايضا التوسع العلمي فاصبح الناس
ايضا يشعرون بمدى اهميه هذه الدوله وبماذا
ايضا ما يلم جراحهم من ناحيه الامنيه لان
كان الجزيره العربيه يضرب فيها المثل عدم
الاستقرار
لكن انا اريد نشات الدوله الان ما هي
مظاهر عظمتها وتميزها ان لذلك مثلت بعهد
سعود لانه العهد الذهب هو مظاهر العمرانيه
حدثنا عن قصر الطريف هذا هو المظاهر
الحقيقه متعدده وجراهم ايضا مختلفه وربما
ايضا لها دراسات كبيره حقيقه جدا يعني
مثلا الطريف اذا اخذنا على سبيل المثال في
الدرعيه برزت ايضا الدرعيه في بنائها
العمراني وايضا تطورها الحضاري في تلك
الفتره فايضا برز ايضا قصر الطريف المشهور
قصر الطريف لانه يقع الدرعيه على طرف
الوادي
تصغير الطرف لان الدرعيه نخوتها القديمه
اهل العوجه العوجه من اعوجاج الوا فاستطاع
ايضا الامام عبد العزيز واكمل هذا المشروع
الامام سعود في بناء ايضا الاحياء
المجاوره ايضا في الدرعيه في حي الطريف
واستطاع ايضا بناء قصر الحكم الذي يمارسون
فيه ايضا القياده والاداره واصبح هناك قصر
مشهور يطلق عليه قصر سلوى هذا اللي هو
البناء الشعبي طبعا هذا المتبقي نعم هذا
المتبقي هو هذا بناه الامام سعود ولا يعرف
الحقيقه ما هي الاسباب التي سميت عليه
سلوى باسم زوجه هل ايضا بسلوى الروح هل
بالطير هل باسم اخر لكن جعله الامام سعود
الذين يفيدون وايضا الناس والشعراء الذين
يلفون عليه في هذا المكان وايضا يدير
الناحيه الحكم والاداره في هذا المكان
وكان الامام سعود ايضا له اوجه مختلفه في
قضيه ايضا حصر بعض الاشياء والجوانب
المختلفه من ناحيه التجاره ضبطها ومن
ناحيه ايضا العلماء وضبطهم من ناحيه
الفتوى
في بعض الرسائل تشير هذا الامر لكن مثلا
هذه الدوله المتراميه الاطراف عشبه
بالامبراطوريه كيف استطاع الامام سعود ان
يحكمها بكل هذا الاتقان يعني اكيد انه في
قناعات يعني مثلا اقاليم نائيه في جنوب
البلاد عشير ولا جازان يعني مش كلها نعتقد
بالقوه العسكريه بقدر ما هو ايمان ايضا من
الاهالي بهذا المشروع وهو لا شك هناك هذا
المشروع امتد ايضا عبرات السنين الى ان
يعني تاطر ايضا في اطار الافاده العامه في
جميع المناطق يعني كثير من المناطق
الجزيره العربيه عندما يتحدث عن اي مجال
هم يقفون على الامر الامني الذي لا
يستطيعون ان يتحركوا من منطقه الى منطقه
اخرى اللي تحققت بفضل الله عز وجل بوقوف
ايضا هذه الدوله وضبطت ايضا الاجراءات
الامنيه فاصبح ايضا هناك القضاه وهناك
الاقامه الاحكام العادله وهناك ايضا
العسكريين وهناك ايضا التكوينات ايضا
الدوله وهناك ايضا تكوين الجيش الدوله
الان واختيارهم وكفاءتهم وعمل الزكاه
فلذلك اصبح الان ولي هذا يقول المؤرخ اشهر
لدينا مؤ ابن بشر يقول اذا ضاعت ناقه او
اذا ضاعت شاب في اقصى الجزيره العربيه في
جنوبها الى شمالها لا يستطيع انسان ان
ياخذها بسبب الامن الذي استقر في هذه
الارجاع فالحقيقه هي شيء ضخم جدا لم يتحقق
لهذه الجزيره هذا الاستقرار الامني وتعتقد
انه لم يسلط الضوء عليه بشكل كافي اللي هو
كيف انشئ تم انشاء جهاز اداري داخلي على
مستوى عالي من الكفاءه والاداره ايضا وهذه
الحقيقه يعني يتتبع الان كثير من الباحثين
وايضا كثير من المهتمين لابد ان يبرز هذا
الجانب الامني في تكوين الدوله ربما ان
يقام ايضا يوم خاص مؤتمرات خاصه ليوم
للامن يستشعروا هذه الاجيال الجديده يعني
تصور اخي الكريم استاذنا ان الانسان ينتقل
من شمال جزيره العربيه الان وضعنا الحالي
من 2400 كيلو الى نجران لا يستطيع ان يدب
في نفسه الخوف في تلك المرحله السابقه قبل
قيام الدوله السعوديه لا يستطيع الانسان
ان يعبر كيلو واحد من منطقه الى منطقه
نعم بسبب الخوف ولهذا لابد ان يستشعر
هؤلاء الجيل الجديد باهميه هذا الامن
واننا نقول هذا الكلام جزافا بل تكلم عنه
الغربيون وتكلم عنه الكثير الحقيقه
يعني يصلح امر البلاد المجاور بالنهايه
اشقاء يعني نشوف الوضع يعني في سوريا تشوف
الوضع في اليمن تشوف الوضع في غيرها من
البلدان يعني اشبه بما تحدثت عنه لا احد
يستطيع انتقل من مكان لمكان نقاط سيطره
ولا هذا تبع مين ولهذا حتى المؤرخين
الاجانب او حتى الذين كتبوا ضد تاريخ هذه
الدوله عندما يشيرون يقول ومن محاسن هؤلاء
السعوديون انهم استطاعوا ضبط الامن في
الجزيره حتى من الاعداء مثلا عثمان بن سند
من اشهر الاعداء الذين كتبوا ايضا خارج
الدوله ويقول وين المحاسن الضخمه انهم
امنوا هذه البلاد فيستطيع الانسان ان
ينتقل من مكان الى اخر لا يخاف وهذا
الحقيقه ميزه ضخمه يجب ان يعبر عنها
الحقيقه الان يعبر ايضا عنها في الايام
وغير ذلك لان هذه الامر مهم جدا
ان تكون هناك مناسبا ليكن يوم اسبوعيا يكن
لابحاث حول الامن وممكن يرافقها عروض
ترفيهيه كذلك هؤلاء الذين بدلوا ارواحهم
في سبيل ايضا هذه البلاد من الشهداء ايضا
هؤلاء لهم حق علينا ما في في منطقه من
مناطق المملكه الا وكانت لابائهم واجدادهم
مساهمه ولهذا اتخذ ايضا الاسره السعوديه
كرمز لهم ايضا من خلال هذه السنوات
الطويله اكثر من 300 سنه الى يومك الحاضر
فلابد الحقيقه ان يستشعر الجميع ايضا
ويستشعر بماهيه هذا الامر الذي نعيش فيه
ونتفيؤ من ظلال تستعرض يعني عدد الناس
اللي ضحوا بحياتهم او ببعض اعضائهم او
بغير ذلك من اموالهم في سبيل صد الغزاه
الاجانب في وسط البلاد وجنوبها وشمالها كل
مكان شقراء في الراس فيضرما في ابها في
يعني حملات لتصدى لها الابطال وهي ليست
وليده اليوم يعني الامام محمد بن سعود عند
قيام ايضا هذه الدوله فهو صرائه على
الرياض استشهد من ابنائه ايضا الامام سعود
وفيصل اوائل الاب الذين استشهدوا ايضا في
سبيله وغيرهم ايضا من هذه الاسره كلهم
مستشهدوا ايضا في سبيل توحيد هذه البلاد
وتحقيق الامن
طيب محمد بن سعود في ذلك طيب عنده نقطه
هذه النقطه المثيره للمشاعر رحمه الله
عليهم نتوقف عند سير هؤلاء الابطال
الشهداء ونكمل الحديث بعد هذا الفاصل لانه
نريد الانتقال الحقيقه الى الى قصه مهمه
جدا فلا تذهبوا بعيدا ما زال حديثنا يحلق
في اجواء الدرعيه والطريف وسلوى
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد في برنامجكم
الندوه صالونها اليوم وفي الحلقه الماضيه
ايضا كان عن يوم التاسيس وهي اللحظه
الفارقه كما عبرنا في الوعي التاريخي
بالذات السعوديه دكتور راشد العساكر
المؤرخ والخبير السعودي في تاريخ الدوله
السعوديه الاولى والثاني وفي اقليم العارض
بشكل خاص كان وما يزال هو ضيفنا حدثنا قبل
الفاصل عن مظاهر العظمه العمرانيه لهذه
الدوله خاصه في اوض صعوديه في عهد الامام
سعود وكذلك قدرتها على فرض الامل الامر
الذي اشاد بها حتى اعداء الدوله بالذات في
مواسم الحج وحركه التجاره وغير ذلك من
مظاهر ابهت وعظمه هذه الدوله نريد ان
ننتقل هذا البعد الداخلي في اداره الدوله
ماذا عن البعد الخارجي دوله بهذه المساحه
مكلا علاقات خارجيه هو بعد نظره الدول
ايضا المحيطه والقوى الاقليميه ايضا في
هذه المنطقه الى ايضا هذا الاتساع الضخم
في الدوله السعوديه وايضا دخول هذه
الانحاء المختلفه في جزيره العربيه تحت
واحد لاول مره في التاريخ يعني ربما بعد
الخلافه من ايام عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله
عنه ولهذا لم تحكم الجزيره العربيه بحكم
واحد الا لهذه الاسره ولهذا استشعروا هذه
الدول ايضا باخطار ستحدق عليهم يعني مثلا
بريطانيا كانت ايضا الدوله لا تغيب عنها
الشمس لكنها استشعرت ايضا الخطر السعودي
من امتداد السعوديين الى المنافذ البحريه
وكانت بريطانيه لا تغيب عنها الشمس لان
دوله تجاريه في المقام الاول ولهذا حتى مع
اعداء الدوله السعوديه كانت في سقوط
الدوله السعوديه ايضا حاولوا ايضا عقد
الاتفاقيه معهم لايضا لابعاد الجذور
السعوديه عن البلاد المنطقه السواحل لان
كانوا يتحكمون ايضا في السعوديين
فاستشعروا بريطانيا ايضا بذلك الامر ايضا
حتى الفرنسيين في بعض الرسائل التي قام
بها ايضا نابليون في فتره من الفترات
ارسال ايضا
للقاء الامام نابليون نعم
ايضا العلاقات ايضا مع الفرس وايضا
العلاقات ايضا مع اليمن في هذه الدول
المجاوره على ذكر اليمن وعلاقات
الائمه في اليمن المؤرخ اليمني لطف الله
جحاف وهي في كتابه المهم درر نحور
الحور العينه والحور العين وهو كتاب كان
نادر شبه نادر الى نعيد طباعتهم من جديد
لانه
سعود وعبد العزيز انه هم عاصر لها في
اليمن بس من زاويه يمنيه يتحدث في كتاب
هذا عن السفاره بعث بها او بعثت بها
الدرعيه الى اليمن للقاء الامام الامام
الامام اليمني ثم ان عبد الله بن مبارك
عبد الله بن مبارك هو المبعوث اظنهم من
اسره من الكرام ثم
حاول ان يلتقي بالايمان فتعطل به المسير
في جبل اسمه جبل كوكبان جبل كوكبا عامر
بالعلماء ومنه علماء يعني ثم طالت مدته
اقامت هناك فذكرت قصه ظريفه انا نبهني لها
الدكتور محمد علي زلفه يقول وهو هناك جادل
العلماء هناك علماء الزيديه لانه لاحظ ان
اليهود في الاعمال يعني
المتدنيه جدا مثل تنظيف القاذورات وما الى
ذلك وابشع من ذلك فقال لماذا تستخدمونهم
بهذا الشكل قالوا لانهم يهود وانه يجب ان
نذلهم او كذا يقول والغريب رد رد عجيب هذا
مبعوث الدرعيه قال لا هؤلاء بشر هؤلاء لا
يستحقون هذه الاهانه ولا يستحقون هذا
الامر هذا يقول للدكتور على الجلفه يقول
نبهني على هذا الموضع من هذه المخطوطه
عالم يهودي في كامبريد لاحظ يعني انتبه
لهذه القصه ما وجدنا هذه القصه ولا بن غنى
لا شك هو هو كثير حتى من المصادر المحليه
لدينا مثلا كتاب درر نحور حور العين كان
لدينا صوره ايضا قديمه المخطوطه وايضا
يشير الى احداثها في المنطقه للسعوديين
قبل تحقيق هذا الكتاب وقيس على ذلك
الحقيقه ايضا غير هذا الكتاب نجد السفارات
المختلفه الدوله السعوديه وايضا لقياداتهم
ايضا في العراق وايضا في الشام فهناك ايضا
علاقات اجتماعيه وعلاقات وايضا علاقات
تبادل مصالح الان فيما بينها ولهذا نجد
بين الفينيه والاخرى ظهور ايضا هذه
الكتابات التاريخيه بخلاف الوثائق التي
تقدم صوره النمطيه جديده ربما غير يعني
غير موجوده في المحليه دكتور راشد هل
اكتشفت اشياء جديده مثلا في المصادر غير
المحليه يعني مثلا زي هذه مصادر المؤرخين
اليمن مؤرخي العراق سوريا مصر الى اخره او
من خلال الوثائق الاسر او من خلال يعني هل
مازلنا موعودين بمفاجات جديده انا اعتقد
البحث العلمي يعني الحافل بكشف المزيد
والجديد من وثائق تاريخ بلادنا ولهذا كان
عرضنا في سابقا يعني نتمنى ايضا في هذا
المكان او هذا الموقف يعني
الايجاد المشروع الضخم للمتحف او الارشيف
الوطني للمملكه العربيه السعوديه وان يكون
في الدرعيه يعني هذا امل حقيقه كل الباحث
وكل مهتم لان الوثائق هؤلاء التي تتناقل
لدي الباحثين ولدي المهتمين لابد انها
تكون في مكان واحد يطلع الك من الناس على
جزء ايضا من تاريخ بلادهم واثارهم الان في
هذه المنطقه لماذا او ما هو نقدك
لكتب التاريخ القديمه السعوديه وما هو ثم
ساسني بسؤال اخر ما هو رايك بمناهج تناول
التاريخ السعودي لكن لماذا تنتقد الكتب
القديمه هو الانتقاد في في محاوله التغذيب
او تصوير هذه المنطقه انها قامت على ان
الناس كانوا يعيشون في جهل وفي كفر وفي
ايضا شركيه وغير ذلك ونحن نقول للاسف
الشديد من كتب هذا الكلام وابتداهم بهم
المؤرخ حسين بن غنام عندما كان في الاحسن
القديمه الدرعيه فحاول ايضا ان يضيف في
كتابه هذا تدوينا او سيره للشيخ محمد بن
عبد الوهاب فيدون السيره الشخصيه ولا يدون
سيره الدوله ولهذا نجد في كثير من الوقائع
حتى في ذهاب الامام محمد بن سعود وفي
جهادي وايضا توحيدي لهذه البلاد مثل ما
ذكرت انه لا انه لا يشير ايضا ان الامام
اتجه لبلد بسبب وجود قبر او بسبب صنم
بسببي كذا هذه للاسف الشديد اسقطها ابن
غنام على الشيخ محمد بن عبد الوهاب وبالغ
في الاسقاط على المنطقه انهم كلهم في
شكريات وكلهم ايضا
وهذا من دابك وشغفك اللي تحدثت عنه انت
كنت شاب يعني صغير شغوف بالتسجيل مع بعض
العلماء ورواه التاريخ القدماء طبعا ومن
ابرز العلماء عندنا كان العلامه حمد
الجاسر فانت سجلت معه مجموعه تسجيلات في
اسئله وكذا وكانه قال لك راي جريء حول بن
غنام صحيح هو هو يذكر يعني
هو يذكر المبالغات الزائده والتنجيز
الزائد في الشخصيات الدينيه في وقته ويقول
ان هذه البلاد كان هناك ايضا لهم ماثر من
قاده وجيوش عسكريين وغير ذلك سعروا في
توحيد البلاد وخدموا ايضا وقتلوا يستشهد
ابنائهم في سبيل ذلك فلماذا لا نركز على
الجانب الامني لان هذه البلاد هي الجانب
الامن هو مفقود اما الج
واجدادنا كل انسان يفتخر بابائه واجداده
ولهذا للاسف الشديد يعني المناهج
التاريخيه في فتره من الفترات وصفت هذه
المنطقه بانهم يعيشون في الشرك ويعيشون
ايضا في جهل حتى قدم الشيخ محمد
بن غنام في هذا الجانب ولقد الحقيقه نقد
مهم جدا يقول المبالغات هذه الزائده يجب
ان يكون الباحث مثل المنصف مثل القاضي اذا
اراد ان ينظر لامر لا بد ان بشكل موضوع
وليس بشكل صحيح دعائي طيب لان كشرت النقطه
المود نفوت الحديث دون التوقف عندها مسمى
السعوديين هل هو مسمى حديث كما يقول البعض
انطلق مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه ام
مسمى قديم لا هو مسمى قديم الحقيقه يعني
الشعب ولهذا نجد في اوائل الوثائق واوائل
المخطوطات لدي بعضها الحقيقه واعثرنا
عليها يذكرون هؤلاء مثلا السعوديون او في
موقع اقدم شاهد اقدم شاهد في الدوله
السعوديه الاولى وجدنا هذه الكتابات ايضا
المعارك السائره ولهذا بدات ايضا تخرج هذه
الجذور الوحده الوطنيه حول هذا الاسم
ينتقلوا من مكان الى مكان فيشيرون الى
رمزيه هذا المكان بقياده هذه الاسره ال
سعود
الشاهد هي مخطوطات قديمه في تحكي بعض
الوقائع التاريخيه زودتك
بالفعل بصور لمخطوطه اثنين في الدوله
السعوديه ذكرت مسمى السعودي سماه الطائفه
السعوديه طائفه السعوديه ولهذا تختلف عن
كتابات المؤرخين الاجانب عندما يذكرون
تاريخنا فينسبون ايضا الامر الديني وهم
متاثرين يقولون الوهابيه نعم انما هذا
يقول السعوديه
في الحروب الاوروبيه القديمه واللوثريه في
تلك الفتره فيحاول اسقاط ايضا الجانب
الديني لكل امر بينما لا ينظرون ايضا
مجتمع وطني قام على اسس ايضا امنيه في هذه
المنطقه
اخيرا كيف نصنع وعي تاريخي مستمر ودائم
حول فكره يوم التاسيس بعيدا عن الجانب
الاحتفالي الجانب الاحتفالي جيد مظاهر
الاحتفاليه الفيديوهات التحفيزيه المقاطع
الاغاني
البوسترات اللي في الشوارع كل هذه اشياء
جيده وممتازه وترفع مستوى الوعي لدى عامه
او ترفع مستوى الاهتمام والشغف لدى عامه
الناس اقصد كيف نصنع وعيا دائما حول هذا
الامر اتذكر مقاله استاذ عبد الله بن جاد
سماها التاسيس ليوم التاسيس انك تعرف انت
تطلع فكره ما هي سهله
تصطدم مع فكره انه هذه
الاساس هو رجل الدين او الشيخ لا الاساس
هو مشروع امني سياسي وبطبيعه الحال سيحكم
بالشريعه لان هذا البلد والشعب شعب مسلم
تحسين حاصل يعني
ما هي مظاهر الخشوع الى ماذا تدعو انا
اعتقد ان هناك اشياء كثيره يعني التكثيف
النواحي ايضا الجوانب التوعويه للجيل
الجديد ايضا الجيل الجديد لابنائنا فمثلا
في المدارس كنا فتره فترات المدارس يوم
المرور يوم كذا يوم الشجره هناك الحقيقه
الزم علينا في اطلاق يوم يشعر به الجميع
الحقيقه هذا حصل باختصار انا لانه الوقت
الى ماذا تدعو مثلا الى الى غير المظاهر
الاحتفاليه لله الدوله ما قصه بس انت الى
ماذا تدعو
ليتجذر ويترسخ الوعي اعتقد انه لا بد ان
يكون هذا على مدار العام وتذكير ايضا
الناس بهذه باهميه المواطنه وايضا اهميه
الاستشعار الناس لوطنه وايضا بيئته وانه
لا غنى عنه هذه الحقيقه مهمه بالاضافه
حضرتك
صناعه محتوى جاد وحقيقي على مستوى افلام
افلام دراما او مسلسلات على مستوى
وثائقيات وايضا مراكز دراسات يحاضر فيها
امثالك من المتوسط يكون على المستوى
المحلي بل ايضا ربما الدوله ايضا السفارات
المملكه وايضا الامور الثقافيه لابد ان
تكون هناك يد واحده في ايضا ايصال هذه
الفكره المهمه لتاريخنا الله يسلمك يا
دكتور راشد الحديث معك لا يمل
والمناسبه هذه لا تمل والتامل فيها وتقليب
واوراقها ايضا امر لا يمل وصحبتكم ايها
الكرام خلف الشاشات لا تمل فالى لقاء قريب
[موسيقى]